après les tirs victorieux des talibans
place désormais à la réflexion et aux
conséquences du retrait occidental
qu'est-ce qui attend désormais
l'afghanistan quel avenir pour les
milliers de déplacés ont fait le point
sur les réactions diplomatiques avec
notre correspondant à moscou antoine
claireaux en direct bonsoir antoine
c'est désormais un fait les talibans au
pouvoir à kaboul
et après quelle relation entretenir avec
eux
oui stéphanie déjà avant de penser à
l'étape suivante il est nécessaire pour
l'otan ce qui ont été sur place pendant
près de vingt ans de voir pourquoi ça
n'a pas fonctionné alors bien sûr les
talibans était une force omniprésente au
moment de l'annoncé du retrait des
forces armées occidentales mais voilà la
vitesse avec laquelle ils ont conquérir
ils ont conquis tout le territoire
afghan a pris tout le monde de court
écoutez
nous allons mettre en place un processus
d'évaluation et d'analysé au sein de
l'otan
et nato des causses car nous devons bien
comprendre ce qui a échoué mais aussi
analyser les résultats obtenus en
afghanistan
notamment en matière de lutte contre le
terrorisme
lorsque nous avons pris cette décision
nous connaissions tous les risques
nous savions tous que cela comportait
des risques et notamment le risque du
retour des talibans
même si personne n'avait prévu que cela
se produirait aussi vite
mais nous savions aussi que si nous
étions resté seul à comporter aussi des
risques
se pose donc maintenant encore plus que
jamais quel ton adopté comment parler
avec les talibans la plupart des pays
attendent encore avant de se prononcer
et antoine la russie désormais plus
particulièrement comment se
positionne-t-elle face aux talibans
oui bien la russie cherche avant tout à
éviter toute forme d'instabilité dans la
région instabilité due au terrorisme ou
encore au trafic de drogue d'autant que
des alliés proches de la russie se
trouve dans cette région d'asie centrale
c'est pour cela que moscou cherche à
mettre en avant le dialogue sur la
plateforme de l'organisation du traité
de sécurité collective c'est cette cet
organisme qui regroupe la russie la
biélorussie l'arménie mais aussi le
kazakhstan et le tadjikistan tadjikistan
qui se trouve être un pays limitrophe de
l'afghanistan
écoutez sergueï lavrov sur le sujet
6e falls au mirror nous adoptons une
position en faveur de la paix de la
prospérité et de la sécurité dans cette
région
de la paix pour le peuple afghan et de
la prospérité pour le peuple afghan ce
cloud chips et en faveur des décisions
qui doivent exclure la possibilité d'une
poursuite de l'utilisation du territoire
de l'afghanistan par des terroristes des
trafiquants de drogue et d'autres
représentants de la criminalité
organisée nous approche dans le cadre de
l'ô tsc seront formulées plus
précisément en vue du sommet qui se
tiendra la mi-septembre à douchanbé ce
sujet sera également abordée lors du
sommet de l'organisation de coopération
de shanghai qui se tiendra aussi dans la
capitale du tadjikistan après le sommet
de l'hôtesse et sur de nombreux sujets
tout comme l'afghanistan la russie
plaide pour une résolution multilatéral
des conflits d'où l'importance pour
moscou de discuter de toutes ces
problématiques dans le cadre de
plateformes telles que l'on vient
d'évoquer l'organisation du traité de
sécurité collective ou encore
l'organisation de coopération de
shanghai sans mentionner l'attachement
de moscou aux nations unies et plus
particulièrement au conseil de sécurité
merci antoine clairon pour ces
précisions direct de moscou